ergebnis man ja ich weiß dass ordentlich
das trifft einfach alles über was
glauben jetzt willkommen beim ein video
ja ich weiss nicht wahrscheinlich auch
qualität ist etwas wovon sound weil wir
badezimmer sind wir müssen allerdings
hier sein und zwar ich habe mich mal
wieder so dazu aufgerafft sport zu
machen ich habe jetzt einen fußball
gespielt aber dann habe ich halt nur
noch youtube gemacht so als einziges
hobby sag ich mal
und er hat mich jetzt dazu gebracht dass
ich fitness mache ich fange jetzt
einfach mal damit an und gucken wie sich
das entwickelt auf jeden fall wandel
gerade im fitnessstudio und er meinte so
ey ich will auch mal andere haare haben
weil ich habe meine haare ja auch
gefärbt und letzter zeit werden sich ja
immer mehr youtuber einfach die haare
der macht auch youtube kopf bekomme ich
später noch zu und habe ich gedacht
kommt machen wir wieder darüber wie
färben haare gucken heißt haus wird und
vielleicht wird es ja witzig kann man ja
nicht wissen wir waren halt einen laden
ist so weiter reden ja sie verkörpert
uns auf jeden fall gesagt die haare
werden grau und ich hoffe die dann war
ich habe richtig angst man sieht
wirklich aufgeregt ich bin verschwitzt
so gesagt bei seiner haarfarbe weil die
halt schon etwas dunkler sind müsste das
grau werden ist allerdings nicht
garantiert deswegen gucken es einfach
wir haben zwei verschiedene mission oha
das schon voll
zum kummer dass der auf das sieht der
aufheller damit die heller werden und
dass man hier ist die farbe lila aus
aber soll ich hab keine ahnung was
sollen also aussehen will varley das
soll genauso aussehen wie dieses l'oréal
typ model hier
diese partner für mainz gekostet ich
wette ihre hat 5000 presse dass
singles bekommen ohne chance ein gesetz
jetzt erst mal von den stühlen reißt
mich mal machen
ich gebe mein bestes ich habe überlegt
ich nehme meine zahnbürste und wirst
oder nein so bezahlt effekt schon mal
alles gut also leute jedes jetzt die
zahnbürste und dass jetzt dieses uhr
amanda unwahrscheinlich
ich fange jetzt einen paparazzo bis 15
was hat was auch douglas ein anderes
video
leute wir haben uns jetzt handschuhe
erklärt weil wir machen das einfach
sofort mit den händen nicht ob es geht
schneller
kein bock dass die zahnbürste irgendwie
noch benutzen
guckt man die werden da schon hell aber
halt noch nicht trauen aber ist okay
also das rad aber es steckt schon groß
das sieht geil aus er nicht okay leute
ich habe jetzt komplett ich sie ganz
tube ist es für eine person oder fünf
wäre auf jeden fall ist die ganze trubel
ist drin das kann auch sein dass es für
mehrere mission ist also um meine
kopfhaut land und meine aber gedreht um
meine augen
ich glaub ich hab gleich blick meinen
laden das ist so wichtig so ich fühle
mich ich fühle mich so als hätte mir
schon richtig langweiliges experiment
gemacht in chemie und träger
das dann nicht grau das doch nur auf
heller werber friedensregelung space co
so leute jetzt kommen wir zum wirklich
wichtigen part
hier ist jetzt die hoffentlich graue
mische also dass es glaubt wird es
einmal verlass dich auf mich ja
vertrauen einfach ja okay bob was machen
wir falsch
ich mach das freundlich das trifft
einfach alles geboten
das witzige ist eigentlich du so viel
wasser hier drauf oder was auch immer
ist und nichts läuft runter das bleibt
alles irgendwie drin und voll komisch
das geht in meinem gehirn ein
okay das liegt jetzt ein also das ist
jetzt wirklich farbe aber das stimmt
übels und ein paar soll meinen augen
ich glaube jetzt alle politiker damit
das besser als heute noch eine minute
dann möchte seine haare und dann wenn
ich glaube mittlerweile nicht mehr ich
hab dich als bestrafung will ich auch
was deine haare fernsehers zeit dafür
nicht schon 10
ich habe meine haare wäscht das thema
gefahren irgendwelchen vögel geschäft
wenn der baum hat zeigt dass wir einfach
zu tode
nun muss sie versuchen gut zu machen
habe ich bei dir und der ist auf jeden
fall versuchen die gut zu machen so gibt
es bei denen wo man es vielleicht 2000
2002 einzig 15.000 15.000 nsa das nehme
ich als herausforderung gefolgt das
nicht mal zum friseur gelten ja das kann
man noch mal ein witziges video machen
so obwohl das eigentlich auch um das
unglaublich hier sieht es wirklich so
schlimm aus der warte ich zeig was also
macht das einfach das waschbecken so
leute jetzt werden die haare gewaschen
mit ganz speziellen shoppen
sorry dass es jetzt machen muss aber auf
seinem channel ganz ohne video
beschreibung ist ja nur ein klick seht
ihr wie das prinzip endlich mal bei mir
sah das team aus beim ersten mal rockig
von sonnenblumen ganze video beschreibt
ansonsten nehmen uns einfach morgen
wieder 18 uhr kommt neues video
und jetzt schaut euch das an mir
aussieht auf einer skala von eins bis
zehn wie gut tiger - sonst ist alles
programm